hi
i'm jacqueline goldsby i'm chair of the
department of african american studies
here at yale
and i'm really grateful and glad to
welcome you
to our department's colloquium series
endeavors
and i want to say a little bit about
this series to give you a sense of
how it fits in our department's work and
culture
and to um you know bring you into the
conversations that we're going to be
starting this semester
um typically we devote endeavors
uh to discuss new scholarship that's
shaping the field of african american
studies we invite scholars critics
artists and activists beyond yale and we
also spotlight the work we're doing here
on campus
to move the conversations about the
black freedom struggle to move the
conversations
about all the ways in which black life
effort has shaped this world
we bring the newest scholarship here and
we talk about it
and one of the great things about this
series
is that we focus in typical years
on works in progress we want to see the
newest work coming out and give it the
best possible chance
in conversation with our graduate
students our undergraduate students
our colleagues across the nine different
departments we collaborate with
actively in our phd program
and with community members too who can
make the time to come
to our our sessions we talk about works
in
progress so that scholars activists
artists critics
can get feedback and produce the best
work that they're capable
of of making but this year is unlike any
other year
and you know the conditions we face
we're facing down a global pandemic
that's killed over two hundred thousand
americans
and over a million people across the
globe
and we know that a disproportionate
number of the u.s
deaths are occurring in communities of
color
we're facing down the disproportionate
killings and brutalization and mass
incarcerations of black people
at the hands of u.s police and judicial
systems
and as tuesday night's debate confirmed
absolutely
utterly and irrevocably we're facing
down threats to american democracy
that are stunning but not surprising
given the republican party's concerted
strategic efforts
to monopolize all branches and processes
of government
given these developments the
african-american studies faculty decided
to
devote endeavors to a single theme
this semester black now conversations
for the revolution
and we decided to invite scholars
activists and
artists whose work stands up to the
challenges
and provides us models for action
so the questions we're going to be
exploring in the sessions we plan
this semester will teach us about these
conditions
teach us about the healthcare politics
of covet 19
teach us about the politics of mass
incarceration and police
brutality and violence lethal violence
teach us about as we will learn today
voting rights
and voting suppression but also give us
ways to think about what can we do to
act
what can we do how can we do it what
difference can we make
so um in a minute i will introduce my
colleague who will
introduce our speakers for today but i
want to
first of all give thanks and lift up our
partnership
with the center for the study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
rhythm as it's known here at yale
um they've been absolutely wonderful
partners with us to co-sponsor
this series helping us stage this event
for us to convene us together community
through zoom
and i want to especially thank the
center's director stephen pitty
who's a professor of history in american
studies and ethnicity race and migration
here at yale
and um lithium's associate director
matthew taneko who worked very very
closely
with our colleagues in african american
studies to
organize this event on the african
american studies side i want to thank
vanessa epps who's our newest staff
member um our new senior administrative
assistant who worked very tirelessly
uh with steve pity with matt taneko
to organize the logistics thank you so
much vanessa for your work
and i want to especially thank my
colleague professor crystal feemster
who is one of yale's most gifted
brilliant historians
who curated this series and did so much
thoughtful um she knew who to call
she knew who to reach out to and made
those connections happen
and the series that we have going
forward
is going to be a brilliant one and i
want to thank crystal
i just got to give her a shout out here
for her work
putting this together um
my last words here about our format
we're in zoom
so a little zoom etiquette um you might
have seen and already clicked
on hopefully that you're willing to be
recorded
we are recording these sessions because
we want to have
as intimate a conversation as we can in
this stage here on campus
but we're lucky to be thinking and
learning with this
activists scholars and critics who are
going to be coming through this term and
we want to make these conversations
available to a broader public
and so we will be posting them on yale's
um
youtube site so um
so we will be recording which means
please keep
your mic muted stay on mute
and when it's time for q a which we want
there to be we want there to be a robust
discussion
uh i'll flag now we're basically going
to be using the chat
for you to submit your questions and
then we'll uh
present those to our speaker today uh
for a deeper conversation
um but a little later on professor
crystal feinstein will explain how that
function will work
but that's how we're going to move
through our time together here
so with that i want to turn things over
to professor crystal femster
who will introduce our
guest speaker today thanks
because we want to live
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
all types of conniving methods are still
being used to prevent negroes from
becoming registered
[Music]
it started when africans were enslaved
and forced to come to this country
there's never been a period of time in
this country
that there was not voter suppression
can't stop
we have to define the job description we
have to define the agenda
ultimately when we show up
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
just
foreign
[Music]
uh
i come here to urge every person
under the sound of my voice to go
to the polls on the 3rd of november
and vote your convictions
um that was really powerful and i know
that latasha is going to talk to us a
little bit about her music
and the freedom music that she's
producing and that's i think that's a
piece that's going to be on her newest
album
but i'm going to let her speak more
specifically to that
but i want to take a moment before we
get into this conversation
to thank the african-american studies
community and the rhythm community
for everything that they've done to make
this possible i want to thank
emmanuel who is our tech person today
helping us out
but i also want to thank everybody who's
agreed to participate
from my colleagues here at yale and
beyond
and i think jackie pretty much covered
the basis but i just want to sort of
reaffirm that and my gratitude and
to our chair for also insisting that we
make this happen
this semester and because it's important
um important work and important
conversations that we need to have
so we are fortunate and really blessed
to be able to open our series with um
latasha brown
and amy meredith cox in conversation
latasha brown is the co-founder of black
voters matter fund
a power building southern based civic
engagement organization
that played an instrumental role in the
2017
alabama u.s senate race and will no
doubt play
um an important and necessary role in
this coming election
ms brown is a principal owner of true
speaks consulting
inc a philanthropy advisory consulting
firm in atlanta georgia
and for more than 25 years she has
served as a consultant and advisor for
individual donors
government public foundations and
private donors who are committed to
doing
social justice marketing so um but she's
also
an amazing jazz singer where
we're going to get to benefit from a
little bit of her
musical talents i think today um amy
meredith cox
is my amazing and brilliant colleague
and friend
who's an associate professor in the
department of african american studies
and anthropology
her research and teaching interests lie
at the intersection
of anthropology black studies and
performance studies
and black feminist theory cox's first
monograph
shapeshifters black girls and the core
of choreography of citizenship
has taught me much i mean if you haven't
read that book you need to read it
um it is a prize winning book she would
receive the 2016
victoria victor turner book prize
in ethnographic writing and honorable
mention from the 2016 gloria
enzo and zalda book prize
and now i'm actually going to turn it
over to these amazing brilliant black
women
oh hello hello thank you so much crystal
thank you so much jackie for setting us
up
latasha how are you
uh i i just have to tell you what a gift
it is to be in conversation with you
especially right now
i cannot think of a better person to not
just
not just help us think through this
moment but to help us develop that
deeper
level of knowing that allows us to
comprehend how we
feel in this moment and what to do about
that right what action to take
so i want to first thank you for carving
out the time to be with us here this
morning i know you have traveled you're
still traveling all over the country
correct me if i'm wrong i think it's
four states in the past 10 days 11
events in the past 10 days
and so so grateful for your time and for
your for your energy
um and thank you for being here and and
talking with me
so um last night and this was actually
after we had gotten off the phone
latasha last night i was thinking about
how to open our conversation
and what to say about this present
moment and so i'm sure you can name
right along with me
everything that crossed my mind and
jackie already pointed to to many of
those things
the ongoing dishonoring of brianna
taylor's life
the fact that our president or the
president of the united states sent out
a clarion call for white supremacists on
national tv
blatantly the generations long
trajectory of the supreme court upon the
death of ruth vader ginsburg
as you well all you know all too well
the gutting of voting rights and our
civil liberties
and the many many many many many too
many ways to name that black lives
has been and continues to be snatched
the pandemic
state-sanctioned murder withholding of
life
saving resources environmental
devastation
this is where i started to name this is
where i started to start
and then i stopped
because i believe we have to make our
arms wider we have to hold a different
type of space simultaneously we have to
claim something different
we have to claim those combinations of
forces and histories
that allow you and i to even be here in
conversation today
we have to name for whom we are holding
the space and who
is holding us in this space this is
where we have to start
now so we will of course we will address
all the things all the things we will
talk about what we are up against we
will talk about black voters matter and
suppression and resistance
in the face of everything that we are
struggling through and with
but i want to open the space from from
open this space from a place
that reminds us of our inheritance our
inheritance of strength
fierce intellect courage innovation
community care and of course love
this is where we want to end up this is
where we have to start
so i want to call into this space into
our conversation
two people that i know we both hold dear
our mutual friend and fierce advocate
for black women and girls tanisha
mcharris
and angela davis
tanisha says my power and my humanity
are not experienced through who i
control
but through who i love and am
accountable to
my power and my humanity are not
experienced through who i control
but through who i love and am
accountable to
angela davis a little bit longer the
work of the political activist
inevitably involves a certain tension
between the requirements
that positions be taken on current
issues as they arise
and the desire that one's contributions
will somehow
survive the ravages of time in this
sense
the most difficult challenge facing the
activists
is to respond fully to the needs of the
moment
and to do so in such a way that the
light one attempts to shine on the
present
simultaneously illuminates the future
so latasha these these words remind me
of my first vision of you
which is that of a time traveler and so
let me explain what i mean by that
i feel that you are rooted and nurtured
by the lessons of the past
the work and blueprint etched in our
very spirits by those who breathed air
on this troubled earth long long before
us
your work at the same time sits squarely
and resolutely in the urgency of the now
as you mobilize all of this with the
prophetic imagination that is gazing
towards our black futures
and you know there's no real distinction
between these three planes
you show us so clearly how to live in
all of them at once how to do work in
all of them at once
guided by the fierce undeterred love for
black communities that tanisha talks
about
that is a source of light that
illuminates how you manifest
accountability
in your political intellectual and
activist work
so i honor you and i want to start with
that grounding with those roots
black voters matter is necessary for all
of the reasons we will get into but i
would love for you to situate black
voters matter in a larger history
because i want people to understand that
as powerful as the work is it is part of
a
broader strategy for manifesting black
political power
right and let me be clear not empire
building but black political power
and so we know that voting is is in this
moment especially so that we can come
up and fight another day right live to
fight another day
but i want you to talk about how you see
black voters
matter as part of this longer political
project
that you've been involved in for decades
and decades and decades
and lastly i'll just say you know it was
how you see black women the mobilization
of black women
and your relationships with
intergenerational groups of black women
being a part
of this foundation oh
freedom
freedom over me over me
and before i be a slave
i'll be buried in my grave
and go home to my lord
and be free i woke up this morning with
my mind
said on freedom
whoa i woke up this morning with my mind
set on freedom whoa
i woke up this morning with my mind said
on freedom hallelujah
hallelujah hallelujah
well the first thing i did right was the
day
i started to fight keep your eyes
on the prize and hold on
hold on you know i want to start in
those songs just what came up in my
spirit because i wanted us to get
grounded
in the history that we think about you
know we think about kind of the the
we have movement as a cerebral kind of
uh
action interaction that we're thinking
about what were they thinking what were
their strategies
we think about the policy that was
shaped we think about the laws of the
voting rights act
that this is the 55th anniversary of
this passage
but most importantly y'all what it was
and what groups
grounds me and makes me connected is
that the spirit of the movement
continues to live in me and i think what
it does is it actually passes down
through generation and generation
i think it transcends time space
that there's something fundamental that
is connected
i feel connected to that is greater than
the us government
that there's something that is
fundamentally greater than what is
seeing those forces
that are beyond what i may even think
that i have the strength
to come up against i believe that my
work
is rooted and grounded as those people
before me
as my ancestors and something that was
greater
that is really driven by our love and
our power and our passion
around humanity you know even when we
talk about the voting rights movement
and the voting rights
and the civil rights movement we really
think about that in the context of
what political rights came out of it but
fundamentally
people weren't doing that just all of
that
work just for the right to vote just to
participate in this system
they were literally reclaiming and
literally standing in their agency
around their humanity making sure that
their humanity was recognized
and appreciated and valued and so i as i
think about the work of black voters
matter
where we're certainly a power building
organization it is organization
what we want to do is to literally be
able to remind people
that their power doesn't necessarily
come from the u.s government or any
nation state
that fundamentally in the very creation
of who they are in their spirit
and that they in fact have agency
and that any decision that is made about
them and their families and
communities they have the poor to shape
that and
man when it is when it does not exist or
when that's threatened
they have the right to demand that
change and so
you know my work i see our work
uh doing now and black voters matter
i am i so apologize you all we are can
you hear me
yes we can hear you okay okay so we are
on the bus
let me i i thoroughly apologize let me
just give some context for people who
are watching
we are working and you were saying that
we went to the in the last 10 days no
was actually half that was five days
right it was five days we've had 12
events and we're moving
and you know i wanted this in this
discussion to be in a part of the
discussion it's really important
you as we're do as i'm just as we're
doing this discussion i want y'all to
know that i'm also engaged in the work
right now
that we're actually headed to um two
hours from
here we're in north carolina and headed
to another another space that we're
doing rallies and i'll share
something about that i am sitting here
on the blackest bus in america
um that we go around from communities to
community
um that would spread two things that
were committed to spreading love and
building power
and so this organization was founded in
2016
um by cliff albright and i and what we
wanted is we wanted to build and how
could
we for years as organizers in the deep
south
we would sit around and think how could
we really be able to support
movement building in the institutional
building and so we created this
organization 2016
we had the audacity to believe that we
would come up with some money from
somewhere
um and sometimes you have to move
because we have been able to be
successful
and being able to raise money for fun we
created the black voters matter
fund first and black voters matter
capacity building institute which is a
c3
for the explicit purpose of the way that
our theory of change
is that the way that you build power as
you build power from the ground
up and that the way that you do that is
that we're not an empire builder
which means how my understanding of how
i i think about it
is we're not going around the country
trying to get
um black voters matter chapters
everywhere that's we have no interest in
that
our goal is to strengthen and build the
capacity of existing infrastructure
that in every community there's
infrastructure matter of fact
even if we can go back to the
enslavement of africans there was always
a system of communicating
whether the the master or the folks knew
the overseer knew
there was always a system of being able
to share food to share
information to even to be able to gather
and so there's
always an ecosystem there's always
infrastructure within our communities
our model was how can we be of service
and offering to build and support the
infrastructure that's already there
those organizations those groups those
folks that
at the end of the day if something
happens in that community they are the
first responders
that we felt that that's who needed the
support and so we think of ourselves
more like special ops
that the work is already going the
soldiers are already on the ground
our goal is to come in and sure up and
say what it is that you need to be able
to provide that
and so in doing that there's a couple of
things that we do and how we provide
that one
we provide resources we provide direct
grants
to organizations in 2018 we funded 180
groups over 180 groups
almost a million dollars that we
provided direct resources and i want to
talk a little bit
about um amy how we did it a little bit
differently yeah i come out of
philanthropy
and i've worked in philanthropy for the
last 15 years of my life and cliff um
all writings also the other co-founders
worked at philanthropy as well
and oftentimes in philanthropy there is
a particular kind of way
that those of us who have engaged in
philanthropy
um in the social justice world it
doesn't feel good often
right you know in many circumstances you
feel like you've got a
um you've got to swear one you've got to
prove yourself you always got to prove
yourself that you are worthy
to receive resources two it often feels
like you're held at a different standard
not
felt it's true that you held at a
different standard than some of your
white counterparts
and three if you're not doing the work
the very way that they think you should
do the work
because obviously they know how to
movement build better than you do right
that if you don't do the work in that
in that um um context that is something
fundamentally wrong and so what lines up
happening it creates this dance
that you have to be not your authentic
self or literally talk about the
authentic work
you have to create and make yourself you
have to contort yourself
to fit into this kind of um criteria of
which
what they they have set out for it so
one of the things that we did we wanted
to be different
and so even as we go into communities we
do research before we go into
communities we do advance
before we literally did anything
close albright and i went around the
seven states in the south
and we listened we went from state to
state
to listen people know what they need
people know what they
want right they know power and so
fundamentally i think one of the
problems is that folks are always
telling particularly black folks what to
do
they want to tell us what to do what we
should be doing what we need to think
instead of actually taking the time to
listen
that there is power in the listening of
people that can actually shape
and tell you what it is that they
prioritize they can also
in your hearing if you're really
listening what they're not saying you
can be able to hear
right and so i'm i'm raising that
because
part of the way that we've shifted our
our funding the way that we approached
it
is that the groups that we had
done
credibility they had community
credibility
[Music]
there have been existing organizations
have a 501 c
3 some of them were churches some were
reproductive rights
groups some of them were um prison
reform
or some of them were the three old
sisters
in the church that just make sure that
everything in that community keeps
rolling right
and so fundamentally when we would
identify those groups and talk to other
folks
that actually we were able to see those
three criterias the first thing we did
is we would give them a mini graph no
paperwork
no questions it was amazing they would
say
well what did i got to do for this that
matter of fact they were suspect
i mean why y'all giving up some money it
was like because we're investing in what
you have already done it's like well
what i got to do for this was like
nothing
that you've already done the work right
what we want to do is give you
this in this investment because what
we've heard from your community
is that you will always serve and show
up when people need you
and so what that did is it broke the
dynamic and shifted the paradigm
of this idea of that people have to
prove themselves to you
what's really in and it shifted the
paradigm and broke up his face
around this grantee grantor relationship
we didn't want a grantee grandchild
relationship
because there's a power dynamic in that
what we wanted is we wanted a
partnership
relationship that to recognize that we
are coming to you to be supportive
to you that you in fact are leading the
world
that you're in the fact of who we all
need we are dependent on you in north
carolina and alabama and mississippi
and so part of our approach even just
initially coming in
to be able to provide a mini grain it
wasn't so much about the money but what
the money did
is it changed the power dynamic in terms
of how people normally get resources
and so it opened up the space i remember
you know one of the groups that we're
working with in
um in southwest georgia he said he was
so
kind of suspect at first he said you
know what i don't want to grab
i just want a megaphone we're like you
want what
he said i want a megaphone so we're like
i mean
okay so we gave him we we bought a
megaphone for him
literally the day he got the megaphone
he's the leader of the end of the play
here southwest georgia one of the
counties in southwest georgia
the day we got the megaphone he
organized some of the folks that he
worked with and when it took over the
city hall we were like well if we had
known that we would have bought you two
megaphones
right and so part of the it wasn't so
much as
and after that time we have been
supporting his work
you know money matters but really
intention matters most
how you show up in the space for groups
are you showing up in a way that you are
affirming them or are you showing it up
in a way that says
once again you got to prove to me black
people that you are worthy
that you are valuable or do you show up
in a way that says
we see the value in what you're doing
what we have found is that the mini
grants the many grants are just to start
you know what what we have found that
even in that conversation
quickly the conversation is never around
money that most of the groups that we're
working with
they're it's not about money right
because we changed that dynamic from the
beginning to let them know even for us
it's not about money even though one
that's one of the things that we offer
we wanted to change the paradigm in
which there is this monetary exchange
and say no the money is just
the money is significant to the extent
that it helps you do your work
what we want to hear about is your work
and we'll figure out what we need to do
and how what kind of support you need
so that we can continue to do that and
so even in our funding process
you know there is a simple so that we
can track
and keep keep records um there's a
simple process now that when people
fill out for our our mini grants um they
can get grants up to ten thousand
ten thousand dollars do their gltv work
or their power building work
the work that they have deemed that's
important around power building what's
really interesting around it
is and this is hard for people to really
conceive of just recently some of our
partners that we know are doing really
really good work
you know we had given a grant to them
one of them in alabama
in february and so we called and we said
symbol we haven't gotten anything from
you are you
we see you doing all this work how are
you paying for this i'm paying for it
out my pocket
we're like why are you doing that and he
said because i didn't want to come back
to y'all that i already got some money
from y'all i was like we're not that's
not who we are that
i'm raising that because philanthropy
has set up a structure and a particular
kind of culture
that people constantly feel like they
are some way
indebted or some way that they can't
come back and ask
the way our process is we told them like
whenever you need resources you come to
us if we ain't got it we're just gonna
tell you we ain't got it but i can
guarantee you
if there's a will in a way we're gonna
have to figure out how we can get that
money
even fundraiser together so even part of
our process
is to really be able to destroy all of
those mechanisms
that have helped us to feel um
marginalized and that and undervalued
and so that people have a role it is so
interesting that is like the toughest
part
to really be able to convince folks that
literally it is an open rolling cycle
tell us when you need what you need
and it is amazing the level of trust
the level of expertise the way that
communities
you know that's why this whole fallacy
that we're hearing around
you know um a people get money they're
abusive we have put
so much we've wrapped up so much of
a a a frame this capitalist frame
that is value that centered money that
makes people respond to it in a certain
kind of way
if you take that out if you take and
take the value out
right and literally focusing on the
value on the work
and the rooting and the routing of the
work
it changes the dynamics all together we
have
no we have we have had a excellent
experience with our partners and we move
millions of dollars
right we trust them they trust us we're
able we even know that oftentimes the
money that we give
part of the time i'll give one example
of how
for people to even understand that it's
not about money a good example i want to
share
is um some work that we did in tennessee
in tennessee there was a community
oversight board there was a group in the
community
that after um several murders
of black men and black women and that
community they wanted to come together
and put a community
oversight board together now what was
interesting is the fop
put millions of dollars the fraternal
order of police put millions of police
union
millions of dollars against this
campaign because of course um
they didn't want this this oversight
board because in many ways we know that
law enforcement
there are many in law enforcement that
don't want any accountability and
particularly accountability
to the black community and so when we
got involved we were just started and we
got involved
and we were their largest funder and i
think that we gave them a total
of somewhere under 30 000. i can't
remember exactly what the amount is
but it was under 30 000. they were up
against
millions of dollars and the most
powerful union and lobbyists
um in tennessee guess who won
they won because what all they needed
it's not money we think
oftentimes that it is the money that
changed the politics no it's the
political will
if you can get the resources to people
who are organized you cannot there are
organizers that are doing work that you
can't even pay them for their work
that fundamentally what they are
offering it doesn't even have a tag to
it
right right there are people that are
giving when people are given out of
their spirit
and their passion and and their belief
system
that is what is transformative money is
oftentimes
limited because it's transactional and
so while we recognize that money is
needed as
a tool to help build the infrastructure
we also recognize that it is not the
driver
it is that those things that are create
transformation
that are the driver so amy i know that
was a long way around
intentionally opened it that way because
i knew through that you would you would
take us there
i mean that would just allow you to take
us all the way there
i was so many lessons i mean that was a
whole sermon but so many lessons
building on what's already there
the idea that you have to come into
particularly a black community and
change it but we know this we know this
from our history
there is life is already there the
transformation is already there so
building on that foundation and it's not
about the money right the foundation
or the fairness that allows for change
doesn't need
money necessarily right and so to think
differently about how we
we um access resources another thing i
want to highlight
is how you have traveled through now
you're traveling around the country we
know this because you're on this bus
with this
sorry janky wi-fi but you're also you
have traveled for many different
institutions
you have traveled through philanthropy
which we i myself think of one of the
whitest most
white and conservative and capitalistic
structures and you have a found you have
found a way
to renegotiate the terms of what
philanthropy can do in our communities
so when we think about the 501c3 in our
neighborhood that's not doing anything
everybody knows it's not doing anything
but keeps getting grant money and you
come into that same community and say no
it's really
that grandmother down the street who's
taking care of all the children
who's providing food that's where the
money needs to go
and rethinking how we think about
resources in our community
and what work like looks like in our
communities um
one thing that i want you to expand on
and move us into thinking about the work
um
specifically right now in this moment
around black voters matter
is listening and i just have to tell you
as an anthropologist as a black feminist
anthropologist
how jealous i am of you on this black
bus right now
i'm tempted to leave my life in america
by the way
and you know because my my whole reason
for coming into the discipline of
anthropology speaking about you know
we're talking about
you know colonial projects you know
these white institutions
you couldn't get much you know deeper
than that than anthropology
but for me coming through anthropology
was about a black feminist model of
being in community in the way that you
talk about
you don't just come into a community you
research that community
you embed yourself in that community and
you listen
and so i'm wondering if you could talk
to us about
from your listening because we hear a
lot on cnn
msnbc you know reading blog posts the
way people talk about
voting in the black community or black
communities the way that black folks
are or are not thinking about voting the
way that trump has
um created you know the voting electoral
process
completely legitimized the electoral
process
and how maybe people are responding to
that um
our choice or the the undecided vote in
the black community not being about
a vote for trump or biden but whether we
vote or not
like these are all sort of the narrative
around
voting in black communities and you are
traveling across the country talking to
folks
and i'm wondering if you could give us a
sense of how the people you are
on the ground with you're literally on
the ground with right now on this bus
traveling through the country how they
are imagining
their vote how they're thinking about
their relationship to the democratic
process
how the kinds of conversations you're
having and what we can learn
that we're perhaps not learning um when
we're watching the news
right or through mainstream media like
what is the real word on the street what
are people what are people feeling and
talking about and struggling with
in essence what is real in the field and
so so what i would like to do um i want
to show a quick clip
crystal if you can show i'm going to
show a quick clip
and then i'll come back to answer the
question
we got power
we're about to get ready to launch our
we got power tour
we're going to be going through at least
12 states maybe more
i'm just really excited now it's a
little bit different than time because
copenhagen
we've got to wear masks we've got to be
socially distant but we
are very committed that we've got to get
in the streets
and inspire and encourage our people in
ways that are socially distant
ready to hit the road ready to see our
votes ready to be socially distracted
ready to mask on our way to pennsylvania
we'll be there for two days
and then we're headed to ohio for
cleveland
register to vote you can even request
your online vote by mail ballot by
clicking the link
or by scanning our qr code with your
camera vote early
vote today cause we got power
in addition to that having the one bus
we actually have two
and they had some babies so we have 20
mini buses baby buses
that are in 11 states um they were going
in and i want to talk about that too
because i mean it's just a bus right
but it's not the bus that makes the
magic it's actually the message
and i don't know if you all were able to
see i want to kind of share
um one of the incidents that happened
early on when we started on every bus
every tour this is our third camp on the
third tour
every tour that we've done um on the bus
you will always you will never see a
black voters matter and it doesn't have
love and power and that's because our
work is rooted in those
those two values love and power
everything that we do is in between
those two
and so when i think about when we're
talking about the work of what we're
hearing on the ground
we approach the work from a perspective
and a place of
that everybody has power we just are
there to remind them
not to give them power but to remind
them that they have power
and to be able to accentuate that and
pull it out and that everybody is
deserving of love
and sometimes we have to be reminded of
that as well
and to be reminded that we are loved and
so in this process
you know what i think is really
important that when we've been talking
to people going on the ground
you know as i said earlier i i do want
people to recognize the most
powerful tool as an organizer
is listening someone and i didn't say
to listen i intentionally said listen
someone and what i mean by that it is
oftentimes when i think about
you know everybody think about how many
times everybody always got some advice
for black folks
what we need to do what do we need to be
thinking i mean we have everybody got
some advice about what we're doing wrong
or what need we need to be doing
x y d when the truth of the matter we
have done extraordinarily well
the fact that right now that even when i
talk about voting
just just just take this that
right now black people vote on part-time
white counterparts
in addition to that black women actually
have the highest voting turnout
than any constituency group in this bank
in this country
the significance of that is in light
that white voters
have received the economic the majority
of the economic political
um and social benefits of this system
the fact that
black folks has only been 50 years where
we've seen our vote be
um um supported and protected through
the voting rights act
for us to be on par it is actually
extraordinary
the fact that we have to go through hell
just to be able to get our registration
to go to vote i'm saying that because
there's oftentimes this narrative
as if black folks ain't voting yes we
are we're voting at our white product at
the same level
as our white counterparts who are
reaping the majority of the benefits
so we've got to shift the narrative to
literally as my grandmother used to say
speak life into people instead of death
in the folks speak
life let's talk about what it is not
just frame us
from a victim but frame us from the
perspective of
we've got more to do and this is and and
certainly we have to expand but also
the the uh democracy should not be laid
at the feet or on the back of black folk
when i think about this country and i
think about the founders of this country
amy
you know the founders of this country
had some
brilliant ideas about theoretical about
democracy
but they certainly were limited in their
vision so much so
that they could even see you and i or uh
uh jacqueline or any of the others that
aren't many of us
on this they didn't even have enough
vision to be able to see and recognize
our humanity
right but at the end of the day so i
consider them yes they were the founders
of this country
but when i say the founders of democracy
i think about those folks in selma
alabama that was on the edmond penis
bridge
that literally pushed this country to be
what she
needed to be to push this country to
really be able to deal with
what is the foundation of democracy if
the vote
is not afforded to all citizens then how
can we really call this truly a
democracy
and so in that space i think we also
have to shift
how we're having this conversation of
what is at stake now
that we're having we have to shift how
we talk about voting
and we have to shift around how we're
engaging around this and so
as i talk about listening part of the
piece is
you know i remember a couple of years
ago when i was first starting being an
organizer
i was out i went to a basketball court
and i'd asked this
young man to i was registering people to
vote and he was very dismissive he was
like
i'm not registered with xyz and i
started to try to evangelize him to tell
him how many people had died and
why he needed to vote and people that
paid the price
and i mean i was just like passionate
with it i was like preaching a sermon
and you know he said um
he said you know he said to me calmly so
you asking me
that i need to put my my faith in a
system
that doesn't even believe in me is that
what you're saying to me
what was i gonna say to that right i
didn't have an answer at a time it took
me about 15 years to develop my ass i
gotta answer now
but it took me about 15 years to really
unders you know to really sit with that
because the truth and what he said and i
mean he went on i mean it was a number
of things he was a brilliant brother
i remember he went on to talk about
there are folks voting and
we've elected this and my grandmother
and them elected these folks and look in
my community look at it right now
like he literally challenged me on the
spot and so it
over a number of years i can still hear
that brother matter of fact
he has been my greatest teacher
around voting because it was in my
listening to him
that i had to really deal and wrestle
with the truth and what he was saying
because everything he said was true and
i say that that is actually in the
shaping
of how i approach the world so when
we're going out talking to folks
um in the communities or on the streets
and they say you know
i don't i'm not gonna vote because i
don't believe that my my vote matters or
my voice matters and i just
they gonna do what they want to do
anyway and you see how my community
operates instead of me trying to
evangelize them
and to get them to convince them to
believe in a system the first thing that
i say
is i'm not trying to convince you to
believe in a system
i want you to believe in yourself number
one
number two i want to know what is it
that you care about because i never say
that people are apathetic i
have not had a single conversation with
any person that didn't care about
something
and so instead of the conversation be
around voting the conversation shifts to
what is it that you care about and then
when it shifts to what they care about
and i listen them i can understand what
it is that they want to see
and they usually connect from the
listing of what they care about and i
said well okay you care about it you're
so passionate about it
what is it that you want to see
different which then goes into their
vision
and then they'll go into their vision
and say well let's
i want to see my cousin got 20 years and
this other dude across town
he didn't he only got six months and i
want to see something different i want
to see that d.a i was like what you want
to happen
i want that d.a that did that to him he
got to go exactly
so if you want him to go guess what
guess how he gets in power
he's elected i make the point
is i make the connection of voting on
how it can
impact them getting the decision or
whatever it is that they want that they
care about
oftentimes we've had voting so far up
here right and part of it
is because people really there has been
an effort in this country for us not to
really lean into
understanding the power of vote and it
isn't by accident that 45
of the population don't participate in
the process there is an active
effort for people just to be proxies
just get somebody to vote for you and go
about your business right
we've got to shift the narrative from
voting being about participation
to voting being about power and so even
in that conversation when i share with
them
is i will say to them i actually agree
with you
when you say that you frustrated and
people been in office and done anything
you absolutely right i'm with you i
believe it i felt it i feel the same
frustration
and so what we have to do is really be
able to show folks
have a honest conversation about the
limitations of voting
but also to be able to get them to see
what power leverage it does have
and so if we're bringing it from a
perspective of being honest saying yes
you're absolutely right
voting is not the panacea i'll be the
first one to say voting the panacea
it ain't the end all to be all it's not
going to solve all our problems
it was frustrating to me when i would
hear people say someone that got
murdered i would just vote no we ain't
got to just vote
but vote is one of the pieces it's one
vehicle and one leverage to power
and so fundamentally we shift the
conversation that the conversation isn't
just about participation it's about
power
and then i go into this conversation to
say
i don't know about you but latasha brown
every decision that is made about me and
my life
i need to be a part of that decision
about you know what somebody's gonna be
it's just like a basketball game which
is all the time
a team is gonna win the question is
which team
is going to really reduce the harm
happening to your community yes it might
not be the perfect candidate
it might not be the perfect political
party
but fundamentally and quickly it's been
very very very rare
that i've had the opportunity to vote
for the look for the ideal candidate
right i see voting a tactical strategy
for a larger goal of what i see
which is to reduce the harm in my
community that is happening right now
to hold people accountable who are
harming
my community and to also put people in
place and position
that actually have some alignment with
the agenda that i have with my community
but i don't stop there
while i'm doing that i am also building
right
and building a new framework for us to
collectively vision
i am building new um new networks
for us to really be able to mess the
kind of power that we can actually talk
about the replacement
of systems that we can start envisioning
what is the next thing
and so my work when i'm on the streets
and when we're talking to folks one
i think there's three points takeaways
one there's an authentic conversation
with folks around
the limitations but also the power the
leverage of voting
two that we make a specific connection
around what it is that they care about
that how voting can impact that you know
it's hard for you to get people to care
about
the presidential election when they've
lost control of their school board so
you start from where people
are and then the third thing is i think
really being able to get people
to shift the focal point so that the
focal point isn't about the candidates
but it's a and it's not about the
political parties but it's about the
people
that fundamentally what the constitution
says it doesn't say we the political
parties
don't say we the candidates it said we
the people and so
over time i think we put so much focus
on amer how do we amass political
parties
the power of political parties how do we
find the the
candidate that's going to come and save
us all that we've
gotten away from the basic foundation of
democracy
that the power always should rest and
reside with the people
yes and i want you know so i'm looking
at the chat and the chat is mirroring
exactly what i'm thinking in this moment
um you mentioned the skepticism that
many voters or potential voters have
i also want to talk about the real fears
and what you
how we can understand what the threat is
so i i'll just in terms of my own
experience my family in ohio
people are terrified of voting and so
when we talk about voter suppression i
know that means something very different
in each state
and it manifests in different ways there
are states and folks that are more
vulnerable than others
but i'm wondering if you could speak to
that and i'm going to pull up as you're
as you're thinking about that there's
there's a couple of comments that speak
to that really thinking about
well when we talk about voter
suppression what does that look like
how do we understand the real threat to
bodily harm and violence that
folks are are dealing with and
considering as part of the reason to
really want to protect themselves
um and then what can we do but i want to
read um
i'm going to read you a a comment from
the chat this is deborah wells who does
a lot of voting activism she says i'm
concerned that when i go to early voting
there are white supremacists at the
library
and i must record their behavior and
possibly be armed in response
everyone in florida is armed needed come
to that
and just in in conversation with deborah
we have another comment
um that's related to that um there's
some social science research that shows
that police contact
not even arrest just contact is a
significant deterrent to black voting
can you talk about how you think about
arming communities to resist state
violence
that is actively trying to disempower or
even kill them
so we're having these questions that are
really thinking about kind of the
the extent of voter suppression and what
that means
as as you know acts of violence and what
how are black communities
processing this how are they thinking
about resistance what are your ideas
around it
um and can you outline for us what those
threats really look like
and what what can we do what can we do
and what states where should we
be putting our energy and our attention
i'm back okay all right i don't know did
natasha did you hear me i heard the
question i can't i heard i heard the
question
um okay i am i am on the back roads of
of north carolina welcome to the bus
y'all
um let me share um
let me share a personal experience that
happened
two days ago
i wanted to show the bus we've got you
know
looks you know it's it's a moving
billboard right
um and you may not be able to see the
details but the way that the
on the bus it has we got power and huge
huge
letters it has black fists
um love power black people all around
the bus
it's about us all of these messages that
are affirming messages for
um and even when we got power in the
middle of it's a black fish raised
and so on the highway it gets its own
share of of
love and stairs and everything in
between but we
rented a um cliff and i um because of
covet 19
we wanted to we had decided that we
would stay in an airbnb and so we went
to cleveland
we left we went to cleveland we went to
stay in an airbnb and normally what will
happen
is um there is a
we will uh the bus will go to the hotel
because the bus stays at the hotel
um and then there's a our security team
or runner team will take us back to
the airbnb well on this particular trip
what wound up happening was
um the bus went directly because we
already have been driving all day the
bus went directly to
um the house we went to the airbnb at
the house and
oh and because we had we were doing a
training for groups in texas
we set out in front of the house for
about 20 minutes did the training went
inside
uh we were with our videographer that
was doing some
interviews
[Music]
i went upstairs and kept working
on our plan for for detroit we were
starting to plan our trip
for detroit cliff my co-co partner
was downstairs doing an interview and
while i was up there on the phone i
could smell
something burning but what i thought was
that there were some
wires that may have been loose um in the
top of the
building and for whatever reason it's
silly me i didn't get up to go check it
out
and so about five minutes later we hear
this
bang on the door like like they're
trying to bring the door down
and like what is happening with
startling and so we go to the door
cliff go to the door cause i'm upstairs
and this woman is screaming and she says
get out your house is on fire your house
is on fire we're like what are you
talking about
and sure enough and we could smell it
and so i run downstairs cliff goes and
we look in the back of the house and all
we see is fire
and so we he goes inside he gets a
a a bucket of water and he goes to try
to take it out
now mind you it's raining outside so
we're like well how did the fire start
and it's raining outside
and so we call the the fire department
9-1-1 the fire department comes
um and they extinguish the fire and then
they started asking us questions and
um what we've later found out there's a
recycle
recyclable being that's by the house the
garbage can that's by the individual
house
that um
was on fire right and so we don't know
we
at first the fire marshal was asking us
well you know is there something in
there were you all smoking we were like
no we weren't smoking we went in the
house we didn't
we weren't we didn't do anything and
later and then i wound up telling them
it was interesting two things that stuck
out to me
you know as we were talking i said and
he was like well well
here because there was nothing outside
i was like and the bus has some messages
on it um like the word black
that some people may find offensive and
so and when i said that to him
it was interesting his response because
his response was like almost like
oh i get it like okay then that makes
sense right
and i was like well damn we can't even
say black hole but anyway um
and he said okay and then and they
brought the arson team what was the
second thing that was interesting
is they're across the street that went
across the street because they were
trying to get good
footage to see who had set the fire
because the fence burned
it could have been a really bad
circumstance at this point we had
decided we were going to leave and go to
a hotel
and um i he went across the street and
there happened to be
a black family across the street and
there was a woman
upstairs that was yelling out the window
saying i am so tired of this
i am so tired of this every time
somebody black rents that house
um they call the police on them every
time they keep harassing those people
and so the man downstairs who i don't
know what her relationship with
but i can tell that we're family he kept
telling her go back
in go back in and so i decided to ask
him but i could tell that there was some
fear
from him and i just kind of asked him
quietly i said
um he had some real problems in this
neighborhood i didn't realize
we were staying in a white neighborhood
and he said yes
i said do you think somebody tried to
set the house on fire
he said why else and i knew he was
talking cold to me
he said why else in the in all of the
fire the fire chief and the arson
um investigator is standing there why
else would a trash can by the house
catch on fire
in the middle of the rain and he just
looked at me
i said okay okay do
you think that we probably should leave
he said yes
i was like okay got it he said
everything i needed to know
we knew you know it was it's interesting
because
as i think of myself as someone
who is courageous um
but racism is traumatic i have not i've
this just happened two days ago
we've had i think 11 events since then
in the same city the next day we had i'm
still
shook to be honest i'm sitting here the
idea that i'm thinking
that just because we got a bus that has
black voters matter on it that you tr
you would you would
try to burn us up and kill us you know
just the reality that it is real
and i can go on with other stories you
know part of
you don't you won't hear a lot of those
stories
out because i've made kind of this
strategic choice that sometimes i think
violence begets violence
and so a lot of times when you put it
out there it creates
all these copycats and so i don't know
if that's the best choice or the
i don't know if that's a good choice or
not but we don't publicize it as much
i mean just even a month ago i was in
louisville kentucky
i went to the stand with the families of
brianna taylor
we went to a gospel concert we did a
training and we were leaving
a police officer um well
uh i'm not sure if he was uh off a
police officer it may have been a state
trooper an
officer took a picture of the bus
posted it in a in a and some white
groups on facebook
my son my brother my brother's mother is
white and friends with someone in
kentucky
literally put that there were riders and
thugs that were coming in
um kentucky to tap kentucky down and the
list went on and on and on of people
saying
actively looking for the bus how they
could hurt us how they could
how they need to cut the tires how they
needed to
do a roadblock to really bring home
today after that event
and the messages that we get because
while we're doing this work
in the spirit of the power and love hate
is real we have pulled up
into places down in south georgia
where when we pulled up just like in the
60s that folks in our face
will flip the sign and say we're close
to keep us from getting gas
or something in a convenience store i'm
talking about in 2018
2020 right i've got all those words but
i can also tell you the story
about when we went to randolph county
and when we're in randolph county this
woman
who um was an elder they were getting
ready to cloak they were closing the
polling sites
and we had a mass meeting and as we were
walking out
she walked we walk out she walks out
with her cane and i'm walking kind of
assist her
and she looks up at the bus i'm actually
moved now she looks up at the bus and
she said
baby does that bus say black voters
matter and i said yes ma'am
because we do and she started crying i
know why she cried
right and i'm i'm saying that because
we cannot uh tr uh of act like this
election is another election
y'all this ain't just about two
different candidates we are talking
about
fascism we are talking about the
president of the united
states that literally gave license to a
white
nationalist supremacist group from the
debate stage
and we're operating like it's normal
right where
operating light is like it's acceptable
right and so i
sh i share that because when we're
talking about moving around in the bus
and when we're talking about fighting
for democracy
literally we've had to hire security to
go
i myself like i'm not just going around
people can see us and we're
we're we're that's real we're excited
and we're doing the work
but even for us just to have the
audacity
to say black voters matter there are
people that seek to do
us harm to scare us i personally even
at my own home um two maybe uh
uh a month ago right receive uh un uh
a pet package that was hand written to
me
to my home even though we've got my
address screw up from the internet
from russia so much so that the fbi
came to my house they consent they they
got the package
all it was what we found out was it was
a little toy like a squishy toy
that had one word that said barofsky on
it there wasn't anything dangerous they
brought the hazmat team out they took it
to the crime lab
but they spent a whole lot of time and
energy and resources
to send something to me that does not
have any value
i'm raising this because when you are
seeing people then i'm not saying this
about me
i'm saying is that when you're seeing
people who are on the front lines every
day
that are literally out there they are
literally risking
risking their lives that we are in a
particular kind of environment that i
don't think we're taking seriously
that we're not understanding that when
trump says the dog whistles
to white supremacists you can go to my
page there are other we
we've got screenshots of where there are
white supremacist groups
that literally a motorcycle group just
the other day yesterday
that saw the bus at a stop and said we
pulled off because we got scared
i mean just the the bottom line is there
is an environment that part of what is
voter suppression
has been an environment of fear and so
when we're doing this work
right we have to recognize what is at
stake this isn't just about an election
and about candidates this is literally
around how are we going to shift the
culture of this country
that we uproot racism and structure
racism in a way
that traumatizes creates harm um
and discouragement to millions of people
in this country
um i okay i first want to say
um thank you and um
we support you and i'm echoing this is
in the chat
and this is from my racial formations
class latasha i teach a class
um that is really about the foundation
of black studies for
first-year phd students in
african-american studies
and this is from that class cohort
please express our love and gratitude
and support
for latasha goodness sending prayers and
positivity and power
um you know i'm thinking you know in
those stories there's so much in both of
those stories
and as much as we understand in this all
too well in this moment the terror of
racism we are being terrorized we've
always been but we see it
in this moment it's the terror of it the
trauma of it
um but i'm also touched by
the the will of the the will of that the
elder
who was coming out to vote and i'm
imagining the same sort of care that you
showed her
you have other examples of how folks are
taking care of one another
right and looking out for one another in
the face of
communities where the police might as
well be the police are terrorizing folks
as they're voting
so you cannot rely on the police as a
source of support or protection
against these violent pope so-called
pole rock watchers
and so um just i'm just wondering about
the ways that
um i guess two questions i i want to ask
you
um how you um
have seen folks be able to take care of
themselves and show up what are the ways
that you suggest
for us to think about um all of this in
the face of terror as we're also
thinking about the importance of the
vote
um and also with that what can we do so
a lot of us
are in um states i'm just i'm just
assuming a lot of us on this
zoom are in states where yes our vote
does matter
but we not might not be in those
critical swing states
um and i'm wondering what advice you
have for for all of us
so how you maybe there's lessons from
your travels from the ways that black
folks are showing up for one another
um but how can we if we're you know how
do we
what what should we do right now right
what should we do beyond voting are the
ways that we can support
folks in other communities what are the
most important things for us to focus on
as we are now
i think it's 33 days um out from the
election instead of the electoral
process is happening now
so we're no longer as you know it's no
longer election day we're in
election season but as we approach um
the voting day as 33 days out what what
should we be focused on what should our
eyes be focused
on where should our actions be rooted
now
so you know just to kind of even build
off even from your last question what i
wanted to get to
is that at the end of the day dr king
said it
um i've struggled whether i
particularly a sizable amount of of my
adulthood whether i believe it or not
i know it to be true power is the only
force that's greater than love
is the only force that's greater than
hate i know that to be true
and so in that what drives me and drives
the millions of other folks
you know um that we work with that are
actually doing the work on the ground
is love and i and and our collective
power
so some of the things that we're doing
at even at the polling sites we've seen
it
you know because oftentimes those same
folks like the proud boys
they're cowards they're not used to
being challenged
they're not used to really being able to
come up against collective power
they're not used to really being able to
be accountable
and so often times i think what we have
to do is we have to show up our
forces and show up collectively together
that's the best way to do it and so i am
encouraging folks um that's this is part
of our um
it was a great question earlier you know
around
whether people i'm not one of the ones
that i think um um
i think that it is it's that we are not
the
you know i believe um oh i forgot my
thought um the
the bottom line is that people are
showing
up at we've got to show up at the
polling site
we've got to say that we are standing in
our power
the whole purpose of our we got power
campaign
is to say that we've got power love is
our power
our resiliency is our power and i'm not
one of those folks that believe that
we don't have the right to bear arms i'm
not one of those people that believe
that um that that folks of color
should not have protection for
themselves i will say this though
i think when we get to the space that we
get in the game of
balance meets violence i mean what we
gonna do have a shootout i mean you know
what i'm saying
like i mean where where's the end in
sight on that right and so i think we
have to strategically
recognize that part of what happens and
even with trump when he's really
challenged on it
you know he talks mad trash when he by
himself and when he's around his crew
but he he ain't said that in the black
community yet about the proud
boys right my point because there's an
element of racist
that literally there's a space around of
of cowardness
and so what we've seen and experienced
that just having people at the polling
sites
just having poll workers and poll
watchers that are trained at the polling
sites
that just having people that are there
that are watching that bear witness
i can tell you it makes a difference it
makes the difference out of people on
the inside act
it makes a difference on the people on
how the people on the outside act
that in some ways what you've got to do
is you've got to really be able to go to
the process
be driven not by hate and fear but be
driven by love
that we love our community to the extent
that we're going to protect our
community that we're going to fight for
democracy that we're literally
going to do everything in our power to
engage folks
the fact that right now there are
children
in cages because they've got a different
passport
color pass for it what is wrong with us
the fact that there were women who had
forced hysterectomies right and are not
able to bear
children because they were seeking
refuge in this country
for us to date or break to brag on some
way that fundamentally
america is the greatest yet we would do
that to other human beings because of
what
passport if you ain't mad and pissed off
something is wrong
we are literally in this space that
we've got a president office
i don't care about his economic policy i
don't care about innocent policy
the fact that he would use hate as a
vehicle
to organize and keep himself in power
that's all i need to know
i'm raising this because we keep
operating as if this is just some
different political election that owes
the democrats or the republicans
or i don't need to hear another debate
for what
fundamentally we know what's at stake
and fundamentally we're going to have to
connect
on how it's going to be different and i
do want to do i want to do something aim
if it's possible with everybody
that's on this call right now i'm just
going to ask you all if you could just
get centered i do this all the time i
just want you all to get centered
wherever you are just kind of get
centered and grounded
i'm going to ask you to close your eyes
i'm going to ask you a question keep
your eyes closed
imagine america without racism
i know we don't have much time so i'm
going to ask you to go ahead and open
your eyes
how many you could actually see
something
i do this exercise all over the place
i do it at harvard i do it in the
community i did it on a basketball court
last night
time and time again 99.9
most of the time of the people that i
asked that question can't even imagine
this country without racism
and so my next question to you is what
has been created and brought into being
in the physical world that wasn't first
envisioned
the cell phone somebody to see the cell
phone
for it to be created someone had to see
this microphone for to be created
there is nothing look around your room
there's nothing that is in existence
that someone did not envision at first
i'm raising this because if we do not
shift and move past just responding to
what is
and envision something different we will
never achieve it because we can't bring
that into being which we
back
[Music]
natasha can you hear me
if you all can ask
my question is
what is your radical reimagining
of this nation
open your eyes
that's where we've got to spend more
time y'all
that's where we've got to spend more
time
we will constantly continue to be in
this rat race
and this hamster wheel of having the
same regenerated conversations
about racism until we can
actually hold something different in our
minds that we want to actually bring
into the world
when i talk about oftentimes i tell
folks around
what is it that we can't reimagine that
at the end of the day
i even think about the work week has
anybody ever thought about
like what's the magic of 40 hours a week
like what's the magic of that
if technology is created so that it
actually cuts down production
why are we not passing on the me the
benefits of the means of production
down to the workers why couldn't we if
it used to take
a thousand workers to make 100 cars and
now it only takes
10 workers i mean um 10 hours to make
100 cars
why don't we keep all the workers cut
down their time
and actually give them more money that
is possible
we can use technology where people could
work 15 hours a week
and spend them and make more money and
spend time with their family and their
children
most of us until cover 19 didn't even
know our kids
we knew them on some we knew on the
weekend but we didn't see them
they were being raised by a system that
fundamentally is even telling them
oftentimes that they're inferior why
can't we reimagine education
why can't we reimagine every single
system in this country
that the economy is not based on how
well the stock market is doing
but how well her people are doing in
this country but
it will never get there if we don't
radically re-imagine
every single system and so i could come
and talk about
you know all my challenges about america
and his system
i could come and talk about what we need
to do in a moment because this is what
we have right now
and so but i also have to think of
myself as a bro
a black futurist i don't have the luxury
just to respond to what is now
that while i am responding to what is
now i am
often pushing my mind to think about
what is possible
because i want to bring it into being
just like steve jobs wanted to bring
this iphone into being
but it will never happen if we're not
spending time
not just fighting what is but creating
some space for us to reimagine and so
with this i'll just i'll stop i'll just
say that with this it's important for us
to know that what's at stake
right now that oftentimes sometimes we
have to make a tactical decision around
voting
that we just give people buy them a
little space
just a little grace and space they may
not be able that person that's in office
might not be the person that's going to
be the
the the person that we need to make a
transform to change they may just be the
transitional person
and that's okay but every single time
every single
thing that is available us every single
tool i love my community
and i love humanity so much that
every single tool that is available that
is within my reach to use
i am actively trying to think how can i
use that to provide
some space for people to create that
which i want to see in the world
and so we've got to also see this is
what we're doing
in the meantime is i see it as a boat
that you're on a big boat you want a bit
you're on the titanic out in the water
and the titanic is sinking and all
you've got is this little raggedy
um this little raggedy um of a lifeboat
that's all you got the goat that's all
you got but the goal is
i got to make it to the shore so that i
can get to the shore and i can create
that vote of which
i know that i deserve in my communities
and so we've got to really be able to be
tactical and how we see elections in a
way
that we're not seeing around do we have
the perfect candidate
right do we have we've got to see it
around what decision because the
decision is going to be made
that is going to create the least amount
of harm in my community
provide some protection and some space
while we build this new thing that i
call that grows out of my
radical reimagining of this nation
um amen i mean i i'm just
satisfied because you responded to my
very last question which was going to
ask you
in your afrofuturistic self to imagine
through your radical imagination what
you should be thinking about and working
towards and you
you did it but i'm wondering if this is
a challenge it's going to be a challenge
for you latasha
but in two minutes there are there's
like three demographics that folks are
interested in in the chat
and you can pick one or maybe talk about
them how they relate together but
folks are talking about felons and
what's happening specifically
um i'm looking at emma's question the
marshall
organizations like the marshall project
have reported that many people who are
incarcerated do not register
wondering your thoughts about that
there's also a question about what the
south
can teach us the 21st century south's
got to say or teach
the rest of the us right now in this
moment and then there was another
question about black women black women
who
give so much and so much is not poured
back into black women
so there's a lot there but i just wanted
to try to do the speed round
okay i just wanted to voice it out two
minutes so the first thing is
i think that when we're talking about
felony re-enfranchisement i think this
is
is is the same thing as i'm talking
about earlier that fundamentally in a
democracy people all people
i believe should have the imp should
have the ability to be able to make a
choice and a decision about decisions
made about them including those who've
been incarcerated
and so if you look at the work i'm just
going to lead you all to the work of
death from me
down in florida some of the work that i
did over 10 years ago as i actually
started the alabama
um coalition to restore the vote and so
i think there's a critical component
around when you look at who's on the
fringes of democracy that's actually
where your what points to you what will
strengthen democracy and so
i think you fundamentally please look
into the work of desmond mead down in
florida the second thing
is when we're talking about um uh the
south
so y'all just follow me with this when
we think about the financial center in
this country what do you think about
wall street when you think about the
political policy center in this country
what do you think about
washington dc when you think about the
entertainment center in this country
what do you think about
hollywood you don't have to think twice
about it when you think about the roots
of
white patriarchy supremacy in this
country what do you think about the
south that's right you're right
the bottom line is when we're talking
about
who is run for you can be as blue as you
want to be
in california and in new york right but
who is running the country right now and
setting policy for the country
is actually southern seniors um i'm
senator mitch mcconnell is from where
kentucky right lindsey graham is from
where south carolina
and so because we've advocated when
we're talking about the south welcome to
the south y'all
we all experiencing it right now that
fundamentally what we're talking about
is shifting the national
discourse around race and other issues
and policy priorities
we're allowing southern seniors to
senators to actually take
control of that process they are
literally running the country it wasn't
by accident
that trump's very first rally was in
alabama and so as long as the roots of
racism
allowed to live unchallenged in the
south then we will continue to see what
we're seeing so when we're talking about
there will be no progressive america
unless we uproot
and strengthen and work in alignment
with folks in the south that's just the
truth
we've got the receipts to show that and
so fundamentally uh what i say is the
south is red until it ain't
that fundamentally when you look at the
people the numbers that are in
north carolina and south carolina and
alabama the reason
why the voter suppression is so great
right is because when you look at who's
moving down south
right and you look up at the
demographics and this demographic shift
that that's where our power is so when
i'm talking about we're talking about
building a progressive movement in this
country
that you uproot the structure racism in
the
in
the south you challenge that if you
change the south as goes the south
goes the nation point-blank period the
last and the final point is
i will say that black women have always
been on the vanguard
you know of fighting for democracy we
even stood 100 years ago in the women's
suffrage movement
right with with uh with our white
counterparts like let's be honest that
what folks most don't
most people don't know is that the
abolitionist movement actually grew up
the um actually birthed the women's
suffrage movement it grew
out of the abolitionist movement and
that in that context that while black
women
were actually on the on the vanguard of
supporting that
that literally it was over 50 years
later before we secured our rights
and so just as we stood with our white
women counterparts
it's going to be interesting to see
whether they stand with us or
and i think that we've got to put that
strategy as well that fundamentally
what black women have been able to do
that in the midst of we understand we we
sit at a particular intersection
of sexism and racism and our ability to
be able to navigate those through those
worlds right
and our ability to touch on um to tap
into our humanity i always say
my grandmother told me that my
great-grandmother was a wet nurse
like who who can have a greater humanity
than to feed a child at your breasts
when your own child can be be sold
right who else has a humanity to nurture
and take care of the very people
who were killing them and were selling
them off there's something about the
humanity of black women
that whether this country acknowledges
or not i acknowledge it
i've seen it we've got the receipts to
show that we have been consistent in
this country and so in that that's why
we do as
one of our five principles of black
voters matter is that we lift up the
voices and the work of black women
i know i went a little over two minutes
but i tried you did that and you got it
all in
and i promised myself i was and i
promised tanisha i wasn't going to cry
and i'm not i'm not going to um i just
want to thank you i cannot
i could not have imagined speaking about
imagination
a better way to kick off this endeavor
series um and i love the title black now
conversations for the revolution i just
had myself on the back i came up with
that
but anyway you you embody
everything that we need so desperately
in this moment
and beyond latasha you know you are just
you are history you are so much of of
what we need right now and you you're
always pointing us to
you're forcing us to not just imagine
what we need but to create that very
thing
you know you and you are modeling that
right now you are creating that very
thing that we need
um i'm so grateful for you i'm so
grateful that you exist that you are
here to teach us
that we can learn from you i'm about to
teach a class now and i cannot i mean
i don't know what we're just going to
talk about what you just said you just
made it
you just laid it all out for us um thank
you thank you
thank you um from the bottom of my heart
and i just want to tell everybody here
there will be more conversations
endeavors
is on and popping um latasha got us
started
our next endeavors conversation is
october 22nd
that's with emily wang we'll be talking
about um
justice and health again something else
that latasha i know you're working on as
you work through
all of these all of these communities um
we are sending you
protection we are sending you lights
we are covering you as you move through
this country on your bus
know that we are holding you um
and please please please i know you are
but please continue to take care of
yourself
um and we will see you on the other side
i will see you all so much
love will win if nothing else if y'all
don't remember anything else i say
that love will win when i'm looking at
the screen even right now the beautiful
faces
and it is this this is us the diversity
is our strength
this is what america looks like that
stage wasn't reflective of what america
looks like
you know that debate stage but this is
what america looks like and so i just
want to encourage you all
to really spend some time radically
reimagining you know
working through this process standing in
the space of love
you know we're being attacked right now
not because we're losing we're actually
winning y'all
we're winning and there's nothing
they're going to be able to do about it
we've just got to be clear about
letting this moment you know the last
thing i'll say is
what how cold all what a diamond is all
diamond
is is a piece of coal put under extreme
pressure over time
that becomes a diamond and what does it
gain it gains clarity
so i'm hoping that in this moment of
great pain and pressure that we allow
this pressure and this pain
to really be able to turn it into
clarity a sense of clarity for us
so that we go forward and we radically
reimagine this country so love y'all
thank you so much when we work together
we win